I have decided to keep a journal to set down all my thoughts and the simple events of my day
I will keep this diary for one year and at the end of that time it will be destroyed
I encouraged my son to enlist.
It was a family tradition
Six months later, he was dead in Iraq.
I was lost.
Thus ends the reading of the Lord, praise be God
So how are you?
I'm fine
No, really
It's been a while since we've talked.
Even a pastor needs a pastor
Did you see the doctor?
You need someone to take care of you.
I want you to be happy.
I know that nothing can change
And I know there is no hope
Reverend Toller?
Yes, Mary
You must come over.
You must come over now
Explosives.
He was becoming someone I didn't know
Opportunistic diseases, anarchy, martial law.
You will live to see this
And you had no idea that he was thinking...
No
I'm so frightened
These kids, they want certainty
You know, don't think, follow
They fall prey to extremism.
It's a world without hope
No, I have not lost my faith
You think that what we did together was a sin
I've seen enough real sin to know the difference
You didn't tell the police, right?
Take a look at your own life before you criticize others
These are frightening times.
We have to be patient
Well somebody has to do something
My hands shake as I write these lines
Can God forgive us for what we've done to this world?
Who can know the mind of God?